the war in the Middle East has been
raging for over a week which means that
already many in the political
establishment are calling for America to
take in Limitless numbers of refugees
one Republican candidate for president
says no my position is very clear as the
first presidential candidates say no
Gaza refugees period we're just not
going to do it and why because we don't
want to import the pathologies from the
Gaza Strip and other places in the
Middle East to the United States of
America America they are taught to hate
Jews they are taught that Israel has no
right to exist the textbooks that they
use don't even have Israel on the map at
all and so this is just endemic to their
culture it's a really toxic culture
that's developed so there's no reason to
be importing that into the United States
and the idea that we can kind of
separate like a terrorist from some
someone that may be a freedom lover that
just doesn't work uh so so we will not
do that uh when I'm president
pretty simple not even all that
controversial the position no
Palestinian refugees is not just the
position of mean old far right-wing
fascist white supremacist this is thst
kind of Republicans whatever the
Liberals say about us that's also the
position of the neighboring Arab states
like Jordan and Egypt it's the exact
same policy no Palestinian refugees
because it's basically impossible to
separate the good guys from the bad guys
the guys who could be good for your
country from the guys who could be a
danger to your country another
Republican candidate says the opposite
you have to realize that whether we're
talking about gazin and Palestinians um
you know all of them don't you've got
half of them at the time that I was
there didn't want to be under hamas's
rule they didn't want to have terrorists
overseeing them they knew that they were
living a terrible life because of Hamas
you had the other half that supported
Hamas and wanted to be a part of that we
see that with Iran too the Iranian
people don't want to be under that
Iranian regime they don't we saw what
happened to Masa amini we saw how they
treat them there are so many of these
people who want to be free from this
terrorist rule they want to be free from
all of that and America's always been
sympathetic to the fact that you can
separate civilians from terrorists and
that's what we have to
do unlike many political commentators on
the right I actually have a lot of
Sympathy for the people in the
Palestinian territories the conflict
there is extremely complex it dates back
in its current form more than a 100
years and it really dates back Millennia
I am not dismissing any of the
circumstances or the people
involved but first of all contrary to
what we just heard America has not
always taken Mass waves of migrants
America has not always said that we're
going to in separate the freedom lovers
from the terrorists we haven't had to
deal with terrorism as a major national
problem for a lot of our country's
history a lot of that story of of of our
country's relation to mass migration is
revisionism from very very recent years
and mass migration is tearing the
country apart we have simply taken in
too many immigrants too quickly it's not
even a knock on the immigrants the
social fabric simply cannot bear much
more without assimilation
we all know that virtually none of the
refugees from this or any conflict will
be Western minded Christians longing for
apple pie and hot dogs on the 4th of
July the Liberals pushing for Mass
migration will see to that if there does
happen to be one who slips through
Biden's going to say no keep that guy
over there we only want the the refugees
and the migrants least likely to
assimilate Mass migration of foreign
people with foreign customs and foreign
beliefs and foreign blood feuds into the
United States will not solve anyone's
problems it will only import them I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show a teacher has
gone viral for telling white people to
stop being mothers we'll get to that in
just a moment first though you've got
two pretty clear positions on the
refugees in the GOP field you've got the
DeSantis View and the Nikki Haley view
well what about the number one guy in
the field Donald Trump he's going even
further and he's saying not only do I
want to ban these new refugees and and
this new wave of mass migration I'm
going to reinstate that very policy that
existed under my previous administration
the Democrats fought us like crazy over
the travel ban you know that they fought
us like crazy I had to go through the
whole court system but after 18 months
in court the Supreme Court finally ruled
the travel ban was totally
constitutional because we want to keep
bad people out that want to destroy our
country as president I also suspended
Refugee resettlement when we entered
office in 2017 nobody had never heard of
it before we didn't want that and we'll
do it again we'll put it right back into
place I banned refugees from Syria I
banned refugees from Somalia very
dangerous places and from all of the
most dangerous places all over the world
I banned them I said I'm
sorry and in my second term we're going
to expand each and every one of those
bands because we have no choice some
very rough people some very very rough
people come out of those areas they want
to blow up our country we aren't
bringing in anyone from Gaza Syria
Somalia Yemen or Libya or anywhere else
that threatens our security so Trump
says not only will I do it I already did
it and when I did it I got a whole bunch
of flak from the Liberals and frankly
Trump got some Flack from the squish
Republicans too you heard the same BS
talking points about the the Muslim
travel ban and how it's unconstitutional
from the squish Republicans as you heard
from the Liberals and it wasn't even a
Muslim travel
there were Muslim countries Muslim
people Muslim groups who were welcomed
to come into the United States but
certain Muslim countries could not
because they were very dangerous places
and it was very hard to vet who was
coming and Trump said if we import
people from here very likely we're going
to get terrorism we're not going to do
it it's not that's not good for our
country I would be I would be violating
my
responsibility to the American
people it's a reminder that Trump really
did reshape the party if you present
these two views to Republican primary
voters maybe to Americans generally The
disantis View no it's just too risky to
accept the refugees from the Palestinian
territories and the Nikki haly view oh
America's always taking in these
refugees a lot of these people are
Freedom loving bring them in bring them
in virtually every Republican primary
voter is going with DeSantis and maybe
most Americans are going with DeSantis
and Trump comes out to remind people hey
I was the one who changed the
conversation before I came along pretty
much every Republican from the
conservatives to the squishy Centrist
moderate types they were always in favor
of more migration some said no illegal
immigration only legal some said illegal
illegal doesn't matter forget about
borders but they were all basically in
favor of more people coming into the
country and it was me and me alone who
said no we're going to shut down
migration especially from particularly
dangerous countries so the party has
obviously changed on that front and and
what the Liberals will do is they'll
come in now and they'll say this is this
is not compassionate you're a cruel
heartless party how could you look at
the images from the Middle East right
now and and not want to take these poor
people in these poor people in these
dire
circumstances but taking in Mass numbers
of people that you don't know very much
about or what you do know about you know
is probably not going to be very
beneficial to your country that is not
compassion I'll show you what compassion
looks like in just a second first though
we got to restore balance to our
political order we have to restore
balance of nature right now go to
balance of nature.com you promo code NOS
living a healthy lifestyle is not easy
especially when you're always on the go
you need simple manageable routines to
ensure you get the proper nutrition each
day which is why I'm a huge fan of
balance of nature balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
make sure you are getting essential
nutritional ingredients every day
balance of nature uses an advanced cold
vacuum process that encapsulates fruits
and vegetables into Whole Food
supplements without sacrificing their
natural antioxidants the capsules are
completely void of additives fillers
extracts synthetics pesticides or added
sugar the only thing in balance of
nature is fruit and veggie capsules are
well fruits and veggies there's never
been an easier way to make sure you are
getting your daily dose of fruits and
vegetables go to balance of nature use
promo code nolles for 35% off your first
order as a preferred customer that is
balanceof nature.com promo code nolles
for 35% off your first preferred order
right now do not wait you owe it to your
body you owe it to your Society you owe
it to Nature balanceof nature.com promo
code nolles you want to know what true
compassion looks like the Latin
patriarch of Jerusalem Catholic Cardinal
Pierre Batista
pitala he has just come out and offered
himself up to Hamas in exchange for
Israeli children who are being held
hostage this is what Cardinal pizzala
says I am ready for an exchange anything
if this can lead to freedom to bring the
children home no problem there is total
willingness on my part then he goes on
he says the first thing to do is to try
to win the release of the hostages
otherwise there will be no way of
stopping an escalation this is a really
important point because I've been saying
on the show now for over a week that the
American interest in this war is to
contain the war to stop the escalation
that's not everybody's interest the
interest of Hamas and Hezbollah and Iran
is to obliterate the state of Israel the
interest of the state of Israel is to
obliterate Iran and the terror groups
that Iran funds the interest of Russia
and China is probably to bring the
United States even more into that war
so that they can deplete American
Military resources and they can perhaps
aggress in the South China Sea aggress
on Taiwan take more of Eastern Europe
but the American interest here is
distinct from all those other groups
that is to contain the war but as the
Cardinal says you cannot contain the war
while the refugees are still or while
the hostages rather are still being held
captive by Hamas that's the sticking
point you've got Americans held captive
you've got Israelis held captive you've
got elderly women held captive you've
got tiny little children held captive
that that is the the sticking point the
reason Hamas did it is so that they
could try to discourage Israel from
obliterating Gaza and that strategy is
probably not going to work either so
this Latin patriarch of Jerusalem this
good solid Catholic Cardinal comes in
and he says take me exchange me for some
of the kids and I'll go to Hamas and I
know they're going to do horrific things
to me and almost certainly kill me but
I'm following in the footsteps of the
Apostles I'm following the footsteps of
the Saints and the martyrs you know that
the Catholic Cardinals wear red shoes
and sometimes people who don't really
get the point of the red shoes they make
fun of it they they used to call uh the
former Pope Pope Benedict the 16th the
late the late Pope Benedict they would
call him Pope Prada because they said he
was wearing these red Prada shoes and
they've compared him to the current Pope
Francis and they said he's Pope prta
named after the newspaper of the Soviet
Union uh not a very nice joke but the
the reason for the red shoes is because
the Bishops as the successors to the
apostles are meant to be willing to walk
in the footsteps of the martyrs and
those footsteps are read with blood and
that's what this Cardinal is is saying
that is true compassion that is true
charity compare that with what the
Liberals want to do they just want to
invite all of the refugees and the
migrants to come into our country
but
inviting Mass waves of migrants to
ghettos that you will never visit that
you Elite liberals who are behind the
mass migration you will forget about Liv
in those ghettos you will never visit
those ghettos you will never have to
deal with any of the problems caused by
the mass waves of migration unvetted
people or people who are somewhat vetted
and we know they have views that are
contrary to our own beliefs here in the
United States that's not compassionate
at all that's cruelty your fellows
citizens that's cruel to people who will
feel the effects of that that's cruel to
to later generations who will have to
deal with the effects of a political
order that's Frid because of a lack of
assimilation of foreigners who've come
in TR you want to talk about true
compassion and charity offer yourself up
compassion means to suffer with somebody
suffer with somebody offer yourself up
give of yourself totally selflessly for
someone else definition of love to will
the good of the other for their own sake
speaking of this war my friend Charlie
Kirk just got in
trouble there are there are calls for
Charlie to step down because Charlie on
a podcast or a radio show apparently
raised questions about whether or not
Israeli intelligence had any forewarning
of this horrible attack by
Hamas Charlie said something to the
effect that Israeli intelligence ignored
the warnings and
I don't know that's not exactly my
position on it I try to favor
conclusions from
incompetence absent firm evidence of
conspiracy but it's not that crazy an
idea it's really not that crazy an idea
the Israeli spy agency is supposed to be
one of the greatest intelligence
operations in the entire world they've
got every inch of Gaza under
surveillance at all times this attack
was extremely elaborate obviously took a
long time to to put together is it
possible that Hamas fooled them it's
possible totally is but it's not crazy
to ask that question it's certainly not
anti-semitic or whatever nonsense
they're saying about Charlie and the
irony of that is Charlie is one of the
biggest supporters of the state of
Israel in in the United States it's it's
it's ridiculous that Charlie hosts
conferences to support the state of
Israel he sends hundreds students a year
to go visit the state of Israel and to
to develop a deep appreciation of the
state of Israel it's just such a
ridiculous attack on him and it's come
from some people some of the squishy
people on the right because they don't
like that Charlie is an effective voice
to get young people to support
conservatism because it's not the kind
of conservatism of Mitt Romney because
it's not the kind of conservatism of the
1990s and 2000s it's it's it's a
different kind I think it's a a deeper
kind of conservatism but they'll take
any cheap shot they can so they'll say
that Charlie for raising an obvious
question is an anti-semite or some
nonsense you know who else raised that
question it's not just the Fringe cookie
radical conspiracy theorist whatever
it's the former director of the CIA and
probably the most prominent living
American General General David Petraeus
he asked the exact same question the
complexity of what they did was really
quite extraordinary were you surprised
by the uh sophistication of the attack
Yes actually I was more
surprised that there just wasn't the
awareness of what was being planned this
is a very substantial operation and the
planning of it alone uh would have been
very considerable but then the training
and equipping and positioning of forces
then the actual conduct of it that all
of that could take place and not Spark
much increased military
Readiness is really quite
stunning really quite stunning and pus
keeps a straight face about it and he
he's not saying the Israeli intelligence
knew and they just ignored the warnings
but he is raising that obvious question
and I mean that that question is going
to be debated for decades to come now
but I don't think that we should be
trying to cancel people for being
anti-semites for raising a question that
anyone who who
thinks about the attack for two seconds
is going to ask I promise you plenty of
people in the state of Israel are asking
that question how could this possibly
have gotten by our intelligence speaking
of intelligence an extremely intelligent
political exchange just went viral and
it was between a lib journalist and the
conservative leader of wait for it
America's evil Top Hat Canada the
conservative leader in Canada Pierre pev
just gave a master class and had to
shoot down liberal journalists take a
listen on the on the topic I mean in
terms of your sort of strategy currently
you're obviously taking the populist uh
pathway um what does that
mean well appealing appealing to
people's uh more emotional levels I
would guess
umly so you're already seeing just from
the the his stance he's just standing
there eating an apple he's totally
relaxed he's totally
calm just that just remaining calm and
relaxed takes so much wind out of the
sales of lib journalists because that's
what they do they always try to play
this game when they when they try to
promote complete nonsense they'll
they'll they'll do it in that really
nice NPR voice so you know Donald Trump
actually uh eats babies there was a
scientific study on this uh yes well of
course Jane yes I saw I'm here in my
business tie and my suit and Donald
Trump eats babies it's been proven and
scientific but they sound really calm
and normal and so somehow it it
convinces you uh to disregard the crazy
things that they're saying so Pierre PV
is using that tactic against them he's
just standing he's just eating an apple
huh okay yeah let's just talk to me this
doesn't need to be a tense exchange talk
to me okay well look obviously you're
using the the you're you're doing
populism huh yeah what does that
mean uh h hum the guy doesn't have an
answer the Liberals just use these
words
populism
gaslighting privilege I don't know
whatever whatever the stupid euphemisms
are and the slogans are they just use
them they haven't really reflected on
them very much so he he throws it out
there and you say hey just can you just
tell me what that word means like in
real language not just in pre-programmed
non-playing character beep boop
regurgitated talking points what do you
actually mean by that usually they can't
quite answer you know who else can't
answer questions your dog because he
doesn't have a rational soul but he can
have good food if you give him Ru greens
right now go to Ru greens.com
Michel you know I'm not the biggest dog
person in the world well my stepbrother
is and while I'm lukewarm on my
stepbrother I do think that the dog
should be healthy and so I sent my step
brother some rough greens and that dog
just keeps saying rough rough rough
because rough greens is so great for
dogs and dogs love it naturopathic
doctor Dennis black the founder of Ruff
greens is focused on improving the
health of every dog in America dog food
may as well be considered dead food
since it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition is not brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that can I know how many times I'm going
to roll that R uh it contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food sprink a little rough Greens on the
food every single day dog owners are
raving about it it supports healthy
joints improves Health boosts energy
levels so much more right now get a free
jumpstart trial bag so that your dog can
try it get a free jump start trial bag
delivered straight to your door just a
few business days go to Ruff greens.com
rfffg greens.com or call 84 4 Ruff
rf123 Ru greens.com or call 844
rf123 today Canadian conservative leader
Pierre PV continues certainly you tap a
very strong ideological language quite
frequently like
what uh left wing you know this and that
right wing you know I mean it's that
that type of about I never really talk
about left or right anyways a lot I
don't really believe in that okay a lot
of people would would say that you're
simply taking a page out of the Donald
Trump
so you use this highly ideological
language what ideological language left
and right I don't say
that the libs will attack conservatives
in public life they will very rarely
listen to conservatives in public life I
remember when Rush limbo was still alive
the libs would go after him he was
Public Enemy Number One not one of them
had ever listened to an entire Rush
limos show not one of them had probably
ever listened to entire Rush limbo
segment they just heard little 30-
second sound bites completely out of
context played on
MSNBC so it's say you always say this
that or the other
thing and and then the conservative can
say when have I said that I I sometimes
get this from the libs when I suggest
that we need standards in public life
and I say we we shouldn't really
tolerate the crazy Pride parades or the
crazy whatever someone says oh here we
go we've got a I thought you were a free
spe speech defending
absolutist huh and now you want to
curtail some speech and I say guys when
have I ever you've never listened to a
word I've said I wrote an entire book
about how I'm not a free speech
absolutist you have no idea what you're
talking about oh I thought you were a
small government libertarian I'm I
promise you I'm not I'm for limited
government meaning I want the government
to be limited to its proper role and but
I'm not you just you're just making
stuff up you just have a you have a
caricature of a conservative in your
mind and it happens to be a caricature
that is easily defeated in debate and in
public life so you you want to attack
that straw man but that ain't us that
ain't Pierre PV that that is not real
conservatives and so then you see this
this journalist start to Pivot and now
he wants to Pivot by tying this guy to
Trump like which people would say that
well I'm sure a great many Canadians but
like
who I don't know who but well you're the
one who asked the question so how you
must know somebody okay I'm I'm sure
there's some out there but anyways
wasn't there you know many people are
this is the classic liberal journo trick
critics say who are the critics well you
know them the ones the ones who are
criticizing yeah who are that who's
you're criticizing but you don't want to
admit it you don't want to admit that
this is just an opinion column so you
have to say well many Canadians are
saying you're just the Canadian Donald
Trump oh yeah who's saying
that uh I don't know well you just said
you said many people are so you got to
know at least like one person right well
uh I think uh someone's probably saying
it keep going the point of this question
is I mean why should why should
Canadians trust you with their vote
given you know not not just the sort of
ideological inclination in terms of
taking the page of Donald Trump's book
but talking about what page what page
can you give me a page give me the page
you keep saying in terms in terms of
turn turning things quite dramatically
in terms of of Trudeau and and the left
wing and all of this I mean you you you
make quite a you know it's it's quite a
play that you make on it so I'm I'm not
sure I don't I don't know what your
question is then forget that why should
Canadians trust you with their vote
Common Sense wow common sense for for a
change we're going to make Common Sense
common in this country we don't have any
common sense in the current government
did you catch what was the actual
question that the journo had for the
conservative leader the actual question
was I kid you not why should Canadians
trust you with their vote that that's
what it just took us three or four
minutes of setup preface
insinuation rinse and repeat rinse and
repeat to get to the most basic question
in Democratic politics why should people
vote for
you and Pierre pev masterfully shoots
down all of it every single bit of it
until
finally it gets to you're taking the
page out of the Trump Playbook no we
just pointed out no one's comparing me
to Trump other than you I don't even
know what it means you're accusing me of
things that I haven't done now you're
referring to what's the page well I uh
um I don't know I guess just because
you're you know you do things that I
don't like and and then FV he comes he
says I just don't understand what your
question is and the guy saywell my
question is why should people vote for
you oh so that's what your monologue
that opened up the question which is
you're terrible I hate you you're stupid
you're a populist you're evil you you're
you're Donald Trump you're bad you're
emotional you're unreasonable you're
this you're that wait what you have a
question oh yeah why should people vote
for you that's how you do it folks that
is how you do it it's I I ceue it up so
often we don't have it queued up for the
show today the exchange on It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia between the actual
lawyer and Charlie Day who's pretending
to be a lawyer that's what you just saw
here just the stammering the hum hum hum
the no answer for anything that's what
if you just
calmly object to the
premises of the Liberals calmly State
your own argument and don't take the
bait they got nothing and speaking of
teaching people things there's a teacher
who's just going viral for for uh
telling white people to stop encouraging
their daughters to be mothers this is a
special PSA for anyone who's raising a
white daughter please stop gassing your
white daughters up to be
mothers stop telling them that it is
their Destiny and their Birthright to
one day be a mother and they will one
day be a
parent but they want to quot but stop
making them feel feel like that's their
Birthright because they often grow up
feeling entitled to children and if they
can't have their own children they will
be entitled to take someone else's child
regardless of Ethics or morals they feel
obligated is their responsibility to
make their family complete d
d men started this men started telling
women that it is their Destiny and their
Birthright to be mothers and that's the
only Niche they have in life denied Ed
stop it stop it okay so this guy is
giving his monologue here in front of
the gay BLM flag so it's not just the
regular gay flag it's like the super
duper extremist terrorist BLM flag or
gay flag rather n BLM flag and flag it's
got it's just all mushed up into one and
kind of looks like a Palestinian flag
too actually because it's got the little
triangle coming in on that
anyway you know that this guy's coming
from a far-left position but what's
amazing is he hits two seemingly
unrelated far-left points here the first
one is women aren't supposed to be
mothers no no there's no there's no
purpose to life there's no there are no
things that we are called to do by
virtue of our sex and by virtue of our
humanity and being made in the image and
likeness of God and having a charge to
be fruitful and multiply no no no that's
not the point of life is just do
whatever you
want which is also implied by the flag
behind him but but you can't quite get
why why is it that he's telling white
women not to want to be
mothers oh
because they sometimes then if they
cannot have biological children adopt
non-white
babies what this guy's saying is that he
would
rather non-white children be orphans
than be raised by white people that's
how much that guy hates white people
that he would rather black and his
Hispanic and Asian and whatever other
kind of children be orphans raised in an
orphanage be killed through abortion
perhaps be left on the streets then have
to be raised by white people and he says
it's just Terri the entitlement of these
white people what entitlement to take an
orphan into their homes and raise them
and invest money and time and care and
their lives into these kids yeah that
compassion that charity that's really
evil and selfish it as
always leftism is not just a little bit
perverted it's a total inversion of
reality and it's an inversion we see
this especially of Christian
faith Christianity says there is neither
Jew nor Greek nor slave nor free nor man
nor woman but all are one in Christ
Jesus this guy says it is a fate worse
than death for a black person to be
raised by a white
family the the Christian faith says be
selfless give of yourself just take take
in the orphan okay the Liberals say no
it it would be that's actually selfish
somehow how does someone who holds those
views who's come to that conclusion how
do they get through their day their view
of reality is so totally skewed it's so
off how do they manage to not just spend
their day walking into walls and falling
into ditches now speaking of kids really
great news while I was away I ended I
was supposed to be away for a lot of
this week there were some snafus on my
international travel which we maybe
we'll get to in a little bit maybe I'll
tell you in a few weeks but anyway I'm
back here that's the bright side I get
to speak with all of you in the mem
segmentum H but the one day that I
missed was the announcement
of bent key which is the daily wire kids
entertainment offering and I was I was
following it you know I'm kind of
checking my phone I sent out some
tweets I've known about this project
obviously for years at this point this
is a project years in the making and
then I checked out the little
Sizzle hi you made it oh hello want to
play I've seen enough these two are
ready ready or not here we
go please keep your arms and legs inside
the cck at all times hurry up the party
is starting soon yeah follow me
where is he going we're going on a
treasure hunt we're exploring the wild
blue yonder it's Chilla
time pretty incredible it's
unbelievable whether big or little
little or
big we all have fabulous adventures
together wow it's time to head off for
adventure look around you is a big music
drum
solo imagine
this all I see is
Adventure I'm not a super sentimental
guy okay but I'm not going to say that
when I saw the sizzle tears came to my
eyes because I'm a man okay I'm a manly
man and I don't do that kind of thing
but I already had very high expectations
for for bent key for the kids offering
Jeremy had promised to invest I think it
was $100 million over the course of a
few years he did that about 18 months or
so ago and everyone kept asking where's
where's the kids entertainment where's
the kids entertainment and he not only
did he make good on it it is it is like
five time five to 10 times better even
than I expected it to be and I had high
expectations we've got four original
kids series a bunch of other kids series
from around the world that we' we've
acquired for this platform that are just
good content for your kids not crazy
woke stuff not going to convince them
that reality is upside down not overly
dactic and on the nose and just good fun
kids content that is going to help shape
their minds in the right way and is
going to entertain them I've I've been
playing it for my kids it's just it's
just amazing and if you are already a
daily wire annual member then there's
some great news you've already got full
access to all of bent Key's incredible
shows at no extra cost this would
typically cost 99 bucks it is included
in your annual daily wire membership for
free this is the biggest single biggest
value ad we've ever given in the daily
wire membership uh you can get bent key
right now at dailywire.com
subscribe head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe we got so much more great
stuff coming but that it's just huge man
and some people are saying why is the
daily wire doing kids content what that
seems so odd this was always the point
this was always the point of daily wire
was not merely to comment on the culture
and politics which is important and we
do it I'm doing it right now but also to
make culture and politics that was the
point it's amazing to see it happen so
anyway go over there right now and
subscribe if you haven't already my
favorite comment yesterday is from John
traml
7377 says Michael I can't tell you where
I am right now Michael halfway through
the show here in the UK no you know what
I actually was not in the UK I that
might have been a slip of the tongue no
I was in a much weirder place and or I
was trying to get to a much weirder
place and actually I when I got to the
airport I found out I was not permitted
into the country that I was attempting
to travel to so I I told you we've got a
lot of fun projects on the horizon I am
not going to say anything more about
that now other than to say uh it was a a
pretty wild 24 hours of travel and now
we're back here in the good old us OFA
in the state of Tennessee and the City
of Nashville and there's more to
come
now the the business side of the of the
daily wire kids offering of Ben key is
it's not just it's look it's obviously
primarily missionally driven but the
business side here is that there's a
huge marketing opportunity Disney all
the other woke companies they flip the
middle finger to Their audience okay you
say you don't want your audience's
eyeballs then we're going to take your
audience's eyeballs and we're going to
give them something you want to talk
about a big marketing opportunity for
conservatives broadly there's a new poll
out from AP NC which says that uh 78% of
Americans believe the country is
trending in the wrong direction only
21% just a little over one in five
Americans say the US is headed in the
right direction this is a downturn even
from a month ago when that same group
found that 3/4 of Americans felt the
country was heading in the wrong
direction and a quarter believed it was
heading in the right direction so you
went from one in four Americans saying
the country is going in the right
direction down to one in five Americans
and and you're just in freefall
okay this is a great opportunity for any
Republican who says that he's running
for president right now or any
Republican who wants to be speaker of
the house that battle is going on right
the second too Ronald Reagan had a great
line in a time for choosing which is
maybe his most famous speech where he
said they accuse us of having simple
answers to complex problems maybe there
are simple answers not easy answers but
simple they are they are simple what do
we want in this country we want strong
families strong communities safe
communities Law and Order we want to be
able to flourish we want to be able to
prosper we want to we want more good and
less evil which means we want to worship
Our God we don't want our churches to be
closed we want to raise our kids in the
right way we we don't want weirdo
teachers in Crazy schools filling their
heads with a pack of Lies We don't
really simple we want to have borders we
want to have Law and Order we want there
to be a distinction between citizens and
foreigners we want to have a country we
want to have a country is that so crazy
and you've got Democrats saying the
opposite of all of that no wonder that
more than three quars of Americans now
say the country is going in the wrong
direction what should Republicans do
Republicans should be normal they should
be normal they should say we want normal
things this was what was really
refreshing about Trump's rhetoric in
2016 is he wasn't reciting from some
political science textbook he wasn't
giving some abstract theory of whatever
people knocked him for it when he said
I'm running for president so we have
good strong communities there were
actually people on the right who came
out and said oh actually that's a that's
a a contradiction of federalism because
the president shouldn't want strong
local communities that should be the job
of the mayor and it's like shut up man
shut up
nerd you eggh head stop it get your head
out of the textbook and put it into
reality with the political
community of course the man running for
president should want strong and safe
communities we want a good life that's
what we want that's what our founding
fathers wanted that's what our framers
wanted we want a sec Ure the blessings
of liberty we don't want to put the cart
before the horse and make an idol out of
some ideological
concept we want good normal stuff be
normal Republicans and you will much
more likely win elections speaking of
trying to fix the culture we've got
we've got to do our our weekly probably
every three days segment on Jada pinket
Smith I don't know why I'm really I'm
really into their I don't know I know
I'm not a big pop culture guy I can't
tell you the last time I saw Will Smith
movie I certainly have I don't think
I've ever seen a Jada Smith movie or TV
show I think she's an actress but their
family Dynamic is illustrative of so
much of the breakdown of the American
family and so you remember she came out
and said she was cheating on her husband
on that show and he had to sit there
like a poor cockled and just bury his
anger inside him and then they went to
the Oscars together and he got up on
stage and smacked Chris Rock in the face
for some reason and then they announced
recently that they've been separated for
years since 2016 now J
can't keep her mouth shut she's
promoting A Memoir of course she goes on
the Today's Show she says that she and
her husband are trying to reconcile if
you find another great love or If Will
finds another great love there's no
finding another great love and I think
that's the point it's like we are in a
place now that we are in a deep healing
space and we are really concentrating on
healing the relationship between us so
it may not be the divorce on paper
anymore there's no divorce on paper
paper there might not be a divorce in
theory anymore yeah no we really have
been working hard oh see okay well I
didn't know I was trying to well wait
you totally missed that on the whole
that's the whole thing wait so wait just
so I'm 100% clear you were divorced not
on paper but now we might be a point
where we're back together we are working
very hard at bringing our relation yes
bringing our relationship
together back to a marriage again back
to a life
partnership
yes okay I I think this is a good
thing I
think there are a lot of people who when
J Smith said I cheated on my husband or
when he went up and smacked Chris Rock
or any of the other just terrible things
that have happened in their marriage who
said man he's got to leave her cuz she
seems crazy and she does seem crazy but
I don't think think that they should get
divorced I might be the one man in
America I'm one of three people in
America it's me Will Smith and Jada
pinket Smith who don't think that Will
and Jada should get divorced I oppose
divorce in in all circumstances I don't
think it's even really a possibility
because I think what God has joined no
man really ultimately can separate so if
they're going to say hey we've got this
horrible marriage it's a horri it's it's
a it's really hard but we are going to
try to keep it together we're going to
try to work on it and bring it back
together I think that's a good thing now
she's using all this weird New Age
liberal hippie language we're working on
mending a life
partnership and we're doing the work of
the healing and that's not going to help
them all that new Agy hippie BS is never
going to help them that's never helped
anybody ever in history the kind of
language that's going to help them is
going to be the old sturdy language of
marriage which is an old sturdy
Institution
that was not con constructed by human
beings it it exists from the very
beginning of human beings because human
beings are the political and social
creature and a coupling creature we are
meant one for the other we are
complimentary men and women okay and the
marriage is a symbol of the relationship
between Christ and his church when when
Christ is speaking about divorce and and
he's hearing from all the scribes and
the Pharisees and all the
legalists and they're saying no you you
can have a divorce right and he says
no no Moses gave you a license to
divorce because of the hardness of your
hearts but from the beginning it was not
so from the beginning Jada Smith and
Will Smith for all of their faults and
all of their errors of thinking they've
got this point more correct than the
modern culture there's a lot more to get
to there's so much more I wanted to get
to today deep fake porn a Palestinian
pizza shop and the Tim Scott
presidential campaign and we just don't
have time because we got to get to a
friend of mine this guy and I go back
over 10 years uh we'll we will get to
those things hopefully later in the week
it is time for the memor room segmentum
a there people who I have missed for
over 24 hours now the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nolles kwes at check out
for 2 months free on all annual plan
[Music]
hands